se están llenando dos camiones pipa con
leche de cabra a velocidades diferentes
los litros de leche de cabra en la pipa
g en la pipa gm después de té minutos se
modelan con la función g de té es igual
a 3 por 12 late los litros de la leche
de cabra en la viva h en la viva h
después de 'the minutos se modelan con
la función hd tm es igual a t que
multiplica a temas 4 elevado al cuadrado
la primera pregunta me dice que pipa
tenía más leche de cabra después de seis
minutos
ok pues vamos a ver cuál de las dos
pipas tiene más leche de cabra después
de seis minutos para eso lo que voy a
hacer explicarme cuánta leche va a tener
la pipa gen es decir calcular qué y aquí
lo voy a poner
de 6 y bueno que es de 6 es lo mismo que
3 por 2 elevado a la potencia 6 lo cual
es lo mismo que 3 que multiplica que
multiplica a 2 que multiplicados que
multiplica a 2 que multiplica a 2 1234
que multiplica a 2 que multiplica a 2 y
4 esto bueno pues esto es lo mismo que 2
por 2 4 por 2 8 por 2 16 por 2 32 por 2
64 64 por 3 y cuánto es 64 por 3
vamos a hacerlo por acá 64 lo voy a
multiplicar por 3 esto es lo mismo que 3
por 4 12 y llevamos 13 por 6 18 y una 19
3 por 4 2 y llevamos 13 procesional 19
ok de lujo ahora vamos a calcular cuánto
va a tener la pipa h después de seis
minutos y para eso voy a calcular h de 6
ya que de 6 es exactamente lo mismo que
seis que seis substituyendo atp por 6
que multiplica a 6 + 4 los cuales 10
elevado al cuadrado y esto es lo mismo
que 6% ok y esto es 600 600 litros por
lo tanto date cuenta que la pipa h tiene
muchos más litros que la pipa gen de
hecho tiene más que el triple de litros
por lo tanto después de seis minutos
puedo concluir que la pipa h le gana en
la cantidad de litros a la pipa de la
pipa h de lujo ok siguiente pregunta qué
pipa tenía más leche de cabra después de
nueve minutos iba de nuevo vamos a
calcular cuánto es h de 9 cuando es h de
9 y cuánto es g de 9h de una vez lo
mismo que 9 sustituyendo a t por 99 que
multiplica
a 13 elevado al cuadrado y bueno 3
elevado al cuadrado
es lo mismo que 169 por lo tanto me va a
quedar 9% 69 y cuantos esto pues vamos a
realizarlo acá arriba a 169 que
multiplica al 9 esto es lo mismo que 9
por 9 81 y llevamos 8 9 por 6 54 y 8 es
62 62 llevamos 69 por 19 y 6 son 15
vamos a corroborar 9 por 9 81 y llevamos
89 por 66 54 54 y 6 son 62 62 entonces
llevamos 6 ok y 9 por 19 16 son 15 mil
521 entonces lo voy a poner justo aquí
esto lo mismo que mil 521 litros de lujo
ahora calculemos quién es
7 979 esto es lo mismo que bueno 3 por 2
elevado a la 9 y esto es lo mismo que
tres por dos por dos por dos
2 x 2 1 2 3 4 5 y 6 y 7 8 y 9 haber 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 y 9
pero nosotros sabemos que de aquí
hasta acá hasta acá hay 192 litros
entonces es esencialmente lo que tengo
que tomarme es 192 ya esto multiplicando
por dos por 2 por 2 2 por 2 4 por 2
porque lo voy a multiplicar porque y
esto me va a quedar 8 por 2 16 y
llevamos 18 por 172 y 173 y llevamos 7
ok 8 por 18 y 7 es lo mismo que 15 mil
536 lo voy a escribir justo campo esto
es lo mismo que mil 536 litros después
de 9 minutos
ahora si comparamos la pipa h después 9
minutos y la pipa g después de nueve
minutos la pipa que tienen más litros
que la pipa h de hecho tiene un poquito
más de litros que la pipa h por lo tanto
en esta ocasión gana la pipa g la pipa
que tiene más litros que la pipa al chef
después de nueve minutos
date cuenta que pasa algo muy
interesante justo aquí esta función
exponencial y bueno sabemos que es
exponencial porque tiene la variable en
el exponente empezó a crecer un poco más
lenta que esta otra función polinomiales
esta que tenemos aquí si te das cuenta
después de seis minutos la función
polinomiales hd tm tiene más litros que
la función g de t bueno esto en un
principio pero después la función
exponencial se empareja pues su tasa
empieza a crecer más y más y más rápido
y cuando llegamos a los nueve minutos
podemos ver que ya pasó a la función
pues no vial la función g de tema tiene
más litros que la función h después de
nueve minutos y después nos preguntan
qué pipa tendrá más leche de cabra que
la otra con el paso del tiempo y por qué
y estoy completamente seguro que va a
ser la función g de temp
una vez que la función exponencial pasa
a esta función poniéndome al la
exponencial se mantendrá creciendo más y
más y más rápido
lo podemos ver y comparar qué es lo que
va a pasar en el minuto 10
si nosotros calculamos y déjeme traer
aquí este color h de 10
bueno pues ancho de 10 es lo mismo que
10 que multiplica a 10 más 4 al cuadrado
que es 14 elevado al cuadrado pero esto
es lo mismo que a 10 que multiplica a 14
elevado al cuadrado lo cuales 196 y
bueno 10 por 196 es 1960 litros
ok ahora vamos a fijarnos qué es lo que
pasa con ángel ge de 10 bueno pues que
de 10 es lo mismo que 3 por 2 elevado a
la potencia número 10
ahora date cuenta que aquí tenemos 3 por
10 a las 9 es decir lo que tenemos que
hacer es multiplicar a este resultado
una vez más por 2 y no va a quedar 2 por
6 es 12 y llevamos 12 por 13 6 y 17 ok
2 por 5 es 10 10 y llevamos 12 por unas
2 y 13 3 mil 72 litros y bueno ya te
puedes dar cuenta que aquí la función
exponencial sigue creciendo mucho más
rápido que esta función polinomiales de
hecho ya le lleva más de 1000 unidades
más de un mil litros y es más todavía
podemos ver más la diferencia si
calculamos h de 11 cuánto sería hecho de
11 bueno pues esto es lo mismo que 11
por 15 elevado al cuadrado ok y esto es
lo mismo que 15 elevado al cuadrado
es lo mismo que 225 me quedaría 11 por
225 ok y cuántos esto bueno pues me voy
a quedar 225 que multiplica a 11
es lo mismo que 225 ok aquí pongo un
cero y después pongo otra vez 225 ok y
ahora sumamos me queda 5
74 y 22 mil 475 esto es lo mismo que dos
mil 475 litros ok y si ahora calculamos
cuánto es de 11 g de 11
bueno pues siguiendo el mismo patrón
esto es lo mismo que esta cantidad por
23 que multiplica a 12 elevado al de la
11 y esto es lo mismo que 2 por 2 42 por
2 42 por 7 14 14 y llevamos una pero
aquí hay un cero por lo tanto ponemos
este 1 y 2 por 36 ok
6 mil 144 litros y si te das cuenta ya
es casi el triple de lo que le lleve la
función 7 a la función hdt en el minuto
11 por lo tanto podemos ver hasta
ahorita que la función que dt se va a
mantener creciendo y creciendo y
creciendo cada vez más rápido que la
función h de la función exponencial va a
crecer mucho más rápido que la función
polinomiales con el paso del tiempo y
creo que hasta lo podemos
visualizar si traemos por aquí a nuestro
programa gráfica dor
déjame traerlo por aquí o en dado caso
puedes utilizar una una calculadora
gráfica dora y ahora en primer lugar
vamos a poner a la función exponencial
que la función exponencial estrés que
multiplica a 2 a 2
esto elevado elevado a la potencia y
bueno voy a poner la potencia x porque
aquí en nuestra variable independiente
ok
quiero este de aquí y además quiero a
fijarme en otra nueva ecuación y la voy
a poner justo aquí que es mi función
polinomiales vamos a poner la función
poniéndole al que en este caso es x que
multiplica que multiplica a x + 4 ok
esto elevado a su vez al cuadrado esto
elevado al cuadrado ok y antes de
fijarnos bien en estas dos funciones
vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa con los
límites de nuestra gráfica lo que quiero
hacer es ajustar el rango entonces
quiero que x empiece en cero y vamos a
ver qué
llegué hasta el 15 ok quiero que mi
escala sea de una unidad ok
activamos bien y ahora vamos a fijarnos
en tiempo jake quiero que empiece en
cero también pero quiero que llegue
hasta y vamos a ponerle hasta 100.000 ok
1 2 1 2 3
ok y me escala mi escala no quiero que
sea 1 quiero que sea en este caso 1000 o
que mil unidades y ahora si si nosotros
le ponemos aceptar vamos a fijarnos qué
es lo que pasa con estas dos funciones
en un primer lugar tenemos aquí a
nuestra función exponencial y es más
vamos a cambiarle de color para que tú
no puedas visualizar de una mejor manera
vamos a ponerle el color verde a esta
función exponencial y bueno por otra
parte aquí tengo a mi función
polinomiales y también le voy a cambiar
el color para que la podemos distinguir
de una mejor manera aquí tengo ya a mis
dos funciones y lo primero que quiero
que veas es como la función exponencial
se dispara mientras que la función
policial lo hace de una manera de ser
date cuenta que la función polinomiales
sigue creciendo pero no se puede
comparar a cómo va creciendo la función
exponencial lo que está haciendo que las
diferencias sean cada vez más y más y
más pronunciadas y es más déjame acercar
un poco al punto que tenemos aquí justo
en el punto en donde mi función
exponencial pasa a la función
polinomiales y ahora que hago el
acercamiento am donde estamos
déjame mover un poco la pantalla para
ver en dónde están mis funciones y las
tenemos justo aquí y date cuenta que si
nos fijamos justo aquí en este punto y
es más déjame acercarme un poco más y un
poco más entonces nos estamos acercando
para ver en qué valor o dicho de otra
manera
cuál es el preciso momento en el cual la
exponencial rebasa a la función
polinomiales la función exponencial que
tenemos de verde va a rebasar a esta
función policial que tenemos de color
rojo así que en definitiva podemos ver
que en un principio la función policial
tomaba valores
más grandes que la función exponencial
que es justo lo que pasa aquí cuando te
vale 6 pero después de eso si nos
fijamos aquí la función exponencial pasa
a la función polinomiales y eso se
mantiene con un ritmo creciente